[Music]
in 1815 the eruption of Mount Tambora
plunged parts of the world into darkness
and marked a gloomy period that came to
be known as the year without a summer so
when Mary and Percy Shelley arrived at
the house of Lord Byron on Lake Geneva
their vacation was mostly spent indoors
for amusement
Byron proposed a challenge to his
literary companion who could write the
most chilling ghost story this sparked
an idea in eighteen year old Mary over
the next few months she would craft the
story of Frankenstein popular depictions
may evoke a green and groaning figure
but that's not Mary Shelley's monster in
fact in the book Frankenstein refers to
the nameless monsters maker dr. Victor
Frankenstein so tense is the struggle
between creator and creature that the
two have merged in our collective
imagination before you read or reread
the original text there are several
other things that are helpful to know
about Frankenstein and how it came to
assume its multiple meanings the book
traces dr. Frankenstein's futile quest
to impart and sustain life he constructs
his monster part by part from dead
matter and electrifies it into conscious
feed upon completing the experiment
however he's horrified at the result and
freeze but time and space aren't enough
to banish the abandoned monster and the
plot turns on a chilling chase between
the tooth Shelley subtitled her fireside
ghost story the modern prometheus that's
in reference to the Greek myth of the
Titan Prometheus who stole fire from the
gods and gave it to humanity dictate
humanity knowledge and power but for
tampering with the status quo
- chained to a rock and eaten by
vultures for eternity
Prometheus enjoyed a resurgence in the
literature of the Romantic period during
the 18th century Mary was a prominent
romantic and shared the movements
appreciation for nature emotion and the
purity of art two years after Mary
released Frankenstein Percy reimagined
the plate of Prometheus in his lyrical
drama Prometheus Unbound the romantics
used these mythical references to signal
the purity of the ancient world in
contrast to modernity they typically
regarded science with suspicion and
Frankenstein is one of the first
cautionary tales about artificial
intelligence for Shelley the terror was
not supernatural but born in a lab in
addition gothic devices infused the text
the Gothic genre is characterized by
onna an eerie setting the grotesque and
the fear of oblivion all elements that
can be seen in Frankenstein but this
horror had roots in personal trauma as
well the text is filled with references
to Shelley's own circumstances born in
1797 Mary was the child of William
Godwin and Mary Wollstonecraft both were
radical intellectual figures and her
mother's books a vindication of the
rights of women is a key feminist text
tragically she died as a result of
complications from Mary's birth Mary was
haunted by her mother's death and later
experienced her own problems with
childbirth she became pregnant
following her elopement with Percy at 16
but that baby died shortly after birth
out of four more pregnancies only one of
their children survived some critics
have linked this tragedy to the themes
explored in Frankenstein Shelley depicts
births as those creative and destructive
and the monster becomes a disfigured
mirror of the natural
like the monster therefore embodies dr.
Frankenstein's corruption of nature in
the quest for glory this constitutes his
fatal flaw or hey Marty ax if God
complex is most clear in the line life
and death appeared to me ideal bound
which I should first break through and
pour a torrent of life onto our dog
although he accomplishes something
awe-inspiring he has played with fire at
his own ethical expense and that
decision occurs throughout the novel
which is full of references entire and
imagery that contrasts light and dark
these moments suggest not only the spark
of prometheus aspire but the power of
radical ideas to expose darker areas of
life
you
[Music]